non non ça va mais vous regrettez ce que
vous avez dit sur qui
je je on ne retarde pas un train
qu'est-ce qu'il y a comment je veux que
je me concentre avec un quelqu'un qui
gesticule en face de moi tout le temps
la crise grimace bah c'est un animateur
mais toi tu commences à me gonfler
je te dis hein
mais quel succès tu as toi
et quel succès là
tu es magnifique aujourd'hui ce
calme-toi non mais non mais
ça m'énerver
juste un conseil qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu
es sûr que parce que j'ai l'impression
que tu es sérieuse
je te parle en ami et j'ai l'impression
que ça se fait zozoter de ouf
[Applaudissements]
comment
[Rires]
attention mais à quoi fais attention
une autre émission dans cet about un
gars qui se lève quelqu'un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention à toi aussi toi
[Rires]
c'est le seul gars quand il va mettre un
coup de pression frère tu l'attends au
moins 10 minutes
mais c'est pas ça et après il vérifie si
c'est la bonne personne excusez-moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez allez c'est parti
Raymond est mort de rire mais il sera
moins dans quelques secondes je sais de
quoi